now did the BBC really have to sack
Danny Baker I have to declare an
interest I was the producer of a show
with Danny more than 30 years ago and
I've always thought him as a really good
bloke
a brilliant broadcaster and one of the
funniest men I've ever met
and anyone who knows Danny knows there's
not a racist bone in his body
so for him to be sacked for tweeting a
comment about the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex baby with a photo of a suited
chimpanzee in a top hat seems a bit over
the top
especially as he was contrived once his
mistake was pointed out to him no one
believes it was intentional racism so
they say and Danny claims he didn't even
know Megan his mixed-race of course he
should have done and of course he
shouldn't have done what he did it was
stupid and insensitive but as a former
BBC director-general I asked would I
have agreed with the decision to suck
him in the Hat when I was there the
pressure to remove him would have been
intense but I rather hoped that I would
have resisted Greg I'm quite depressed
about the fact that we're having this
debate if I'm honest because you're
somebody who I think generally sees
yourself as an ally of progress and as
director general of the BBC he made a
number of comments which were championed
by people who wanted to see more
diversity in broadcasting which by the
way is not a battle that's been won it's
an ongoing struggle I think that I'm
ambivalent about this because I don't
really feel like I should debate you
about whether this tweet was racist do
you think it was racist or do we need to
argue about whether it was actually
racist in the first place I think it
could easily be interpreted as being
racist yes it could be non racist oh no
I think it's a it's it would be seen as
racist what the discussion is about
intent I think so and well it could be
non racist in the context of if you
didn't intend it to be racist he could
have what he could have intended was
that we as a society parade royal babies
around like performing monkeys that's
what he's which is what he said he meant
he compared the
and the first round if we be circles if
we begin to separate intent from race to
actions and cannot see the distinction
between racist behavior and so on being
a racist then I shudder to think the
kind of society we're going to end up in
because everybody will be declared
racist all the time for microaggressions
which is where the far-left are taking
us yes the action was racist but no he
didn't mean to be racist which is why
you immediate apologized for it and
deleted it and then lost his job and
people still wanted to take him to the
police again security can I just show
you a clip I think of Danny being
interviewed by Sky News because I think
he explains for himself what happened
did you think about it when you were
doing it did you know otherwise I'd have
to be some kind of slathering secret
racist of promise you I nobody invites
this onto themselves no I no idea into
somebody of it minute somebody sitting
that's what's it's down down down on the
radio for years I did monkeys dressed as
famous people plus fairground music
because I'm still one of those people
who thinks monkeys are quite funny do
you know in that thought do you accept
that some people will think though that
it's at very best a bit naive oh that's
what it is I think that brings you into
this discussion about intent he did not
intend to be racist I'm neither
I only think if if he'd been on the
staff of the BBC as opposed to being a
freelance if he'd been on the staff they
would have had to have a proper
investigation they'd have gone through
the whole process and I suspect he might
not have gone but because someone had a
knee-jerk reaction because they
understood the sort of flack that we're
gonna get I think they got rid of him
and I'm I I have to separate the fact
that I know him in have known him quite
well and then nobody's like I've never
met him before in my life and never
heard of him before this can that can I
ask you a question of what do you think
I I think it was unintended racism do
you think that it is right that he loses
his job and possibly his career over
that I think I'm going on strike in this
debate if I'm honest because you know
what it is
I'm the only black person in this space
I'm the only black woman in this space
and it's not the first time that I am
being called upon
and I'm feeling and supportive vibes
it's so exhausting to have to sit here
to and communicate a daily lived
experience these the kind of things that
happen every day in your life as a black
person in this country yesterday I was
talking to a mixed-race girl who tried
to kill herself when she finished school
because of daily things that made her
feel dehumanized it's regular and it's
everywhere and then what you see is that
people like you Greg line up to defend
your friends and say I know him he's a
nice guy it's fine it's harmless he
didn't mean it
you have no idea how it feels to have
someone making monkey noises at you when
you're doing your job and you know he's
a football supporter he should know this
is something that the best football
players in the country so they can't
wait to see the back of their game
because of the emotional trauma of
having command no not once at all
already dozens of footballers and not
just at the Premier League regular local
clubs kids playing teams on the weekend
saying that having monkey noises is a
regular part having I'm just done I'm
not a thank you for being I'm not going
to communicate to you what is wrong with
it you should know you should know
better I have fought a lot over this I
can see how upset you and I'm very sorry
that you're upset about this but but but
do you think that if someone let me ask
you a question in this job we all live
in on radio on in television we're all
capable you know we live in fear of
cocking it up of saying something that
well I do I live in fear of saying the
wrong thing and and it offends somebody
that I didn't mean to offend I asked it
before do you think it's right that he
loses his career over this having I
don't think it will lose his grip he'll
let me let's get out for a second and
I'll take the under course enough we can
give her I don't he will lose his career
cause he's a supremely talented man he
was stupid he was Cranston son
pardonable it was undoubtedly eraser
what I find extraordinary is this a man
who has done some great product and I
admire him and I he's beaten me to
awards on many occasions and well done
to him he works for a station that's all
about news and sport yeah he doesn't
know who Megan Markel is he doesn't know
that she's mixed race he didn't know
which practices or judges have voting
and he doesn't know about the problem of
racism in these people
we've got to stop being cowardly about
this to me I thought I really respect
with your feelings what you said but
there is a difference between principle
and how people feel people feel very
aggrieved by this and have the right to
that doesn't make him a racist it makes
him stupid yes now if at the end of the
day if we're going to encourage that
kind of world where feelings equal fact
there was a professor in Harvard the
first african-american Dean of the
Faculty of Law
just this week was sacked by Harvard
because feelings equal fact for people
today and I feel as strongly about this
as you do because I've fallen victim to
this kind of thinking he was sacked why
because he agreed as a law professor to
go on to Harvey Weinstein's legal
defense team and they they sacked him
because the students said they now feel
unsafe what they didn't consider is he
was the first African American law
faculty Dean and so everyone suffers
from this thinking if feelings equal
fanart I thought long and hard before I
did this and actually I went on your
show you did and I hadn't made up my
mind in that stage I wasn't sure then
because I just come back mistakes then I
looked at it more much and I find it
very difficult and I can understand
exactly your position I also understand
your position in that every time we have
something about Vice why does that come
to you is being stupid a crime is being
you know he was in what we it was
investigated by the police also can you
be a can you be something a sexist a
racist a homophobe if you weren't
intending the meaning of those words
when you said something that has the
consequence of being racist sexist or
homophobic
no because intent matters I think it
does matter because also I've worked
again I understand the history of this
slur but we've got to look I suffer from
racism as well we've got to distinguish
between intent intended racism and
accidental racism otherwise we don't
give people the chance to redeem
themselves if everything is racist
whether you intended it or not then
there's no forgiveness there's no
redemption
there's no Bala concept of forget is no
apology why apologize if you're guilty
anywhere then that's it you can't change
it you know and you know it's do you not
accept that I mean you're sitting back
and I get your I'm ready to so he I
haven't had
chance to come in it was to your
question Carol you know my issue is that
everybody makes the person who does the
racist thing the victim so you were on
the other right that he was act greg
thing he's a nice guy he's gonna lose
his job you know how if he the victim in
sorry this is a pregnant woman who had
to arrange new levels of protection
because the amount of racist abuse she
was receiving which escalated when she
announced she was pregnant she's always
had racist abuse but when she announced
her pregnancy it multiplied because
there is so much toxic racism in our
society to anybody who's fault that's
not Danny Baker spot but what is Danny
Baker's fault is that he did something
which was so offensive that when I first
saw it I actually thought it was a prank
I just thought nobody nobody who the
babies think of the platform she could
be stupid enough to say this and not
intend it to be racist because it is one
of and we could talk about unintended
racism or microaggressions this is none
of those this is the most blatant
clear-cut example of racism is that
generations of people have recognized
this there's no vertebrae stroke within
people's lifetimes black people were
still being compared to monkeys and
dehumanized regular slacking is right so
I'm not interested in him I'm not
interested in him or what happens to him
by the way he's already done a show
which was more successful than his
previous shows since he's been sacked so
if you're worried about his career then
I suspect worried about not interested
I'm worried about the millions of black
people who regularly live with this kind
of abuse and then have to be in spaces
like this where everybody denies it's a
problem that is something that I could
not feel more strongly about and I'm
living it right now in this conversation
it's not it's not good enough